hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es wieder kein rezept video
und zwar hatte ich euch einmal in einem
schwangerschafts update jetzt mal einen
kinderwagen vorgestellt und da kam eben
ganz auf die anfrage und die nachfrage
könntest du dir nicht mal die baby
erstausstattung zeigen und das möchte
ich jetzt in diesem video machen aber
vielleicht kurz vorweg also ich hab das
ja auch schon letztes mal angedeutet
man kann ja wirklich bei babysachen sich
dumm und dämlich kaufen und wirklich die
ganze wohnung vollstellen
aber für mich habe ich einfach
entschieden dass wir gar nicht so viel
brauchen
man braucht auch im alltag wirklich
nicht so arg viel und ich zeige mich
jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz was eben für
mich so die sinnvollen sachen waren de
wir uns an geschafft haben und ich denke
wir gehen darf jetzt einfach mal direkt
ins schlafzimmer
jawohl im schlaf zu beginn schwachsinn
zuerst zeige ich euch jetzt die für mich
wichtigste anschaffung und zwar ist es
für mich das babybett und zwar geht es
sei ganz verschiedene es gibt ein
stubenwagen es gibt studien bett es gibt
bei stellt es gibt ein separates
babybett und ich habe für mich dieses
beispiel bett also wir haben das im
krankenhaus gesehen und zwar ist es ein
babybett beispiel war bei stellt bett
das kann ich nämlich hier direkt an das
elternbett einfach anschließen also ich
zeige euch das jetzt auch gleich und ich
finde es halt perfekt weil man kann halt
so rollen darunter machen das haben wir
auch gemacht und ich kann dann dieses
bett nehmen und praktisch als
stubenwagen dann auch nutzen und zwar
ist es für mich halt immer ganz wichtig
wenn se bi im schlafzimmer schläft also
sollte es auf jeden fall weil das baby
braucht am anfang einfach die nähe und
man muss ja auch öfter stillen oder wenn
man auch nicht stellt die flasche geben
und das baby sollte einfach ihren eltern
nähe sein
und ich fand es halt wichtig dass es
direkt an meinem bett ist weil ich dann
einfach direkt aus dem schlaf heraus
praktisch das baby auch immer sehen kann
freundinnen eine freundin von mir die
sabrina kati und arena
die haben zum beispiel ein stubenwagen
und zwar ist es so ein schöner corp und
da steht dann halt separat der nachteil
da erschallt du sie schon das baby nicht
direkt das heißt du musst auch von außen
bett immer aussteigen und aufstehen und
dann in den wagen rein gucken und
herstellt direkt den blick aufs baby
gerade am anfang macht man sich ja immer
sorgen
und bin halt immer gucken dass es dem
baby eben auch gut geht und dieses habe
ich jetzt bei mir auch im krankenhaus
gehabt deswegen haben wir das dann auch
gekauft ich hab das übrigens gebraucht
einfach bei meiner freundin gekauft die
hat nämlich nicht mehr gebraucht was
baby schon größer war und das war dann
wirklich ideal also ich hab im
krankenhaus noch zu mir gesagt du das
alte bett von samira das war kaputt ist
konnten wir leider nicht mehr nehmen
deswegen haben wir dann mit unserer
freundin gesprochen und gesagt sie hat
es noch deswegen haben wir es einfach
bei ihr gebraucht gekauft und idealist
daran halt ich kam da auch noch dieses
gitter davor machen und kann das
festmachen und daneben den wagen in die
wohnung rheinfalls was ist in die
wohnung rein ins wohnzimmer zum beispiel
reinfahren und dann einfach neben das so
vorstellen und dann hab ich's baby da
auch eben mit dabei und wollen pochen
oder beim kochen da ist nämlich auch
einfach nimmt der arbeitsfläche mit
dabei und ich finds halt wirklich ideal
vor allem kann ich dieses bett
einstellen auf jede bett höhe und kann
dann einfach des einhaken und das www
liegt das sicher drin und was ich noch
richtig toll finde und zwar habe ich das
hier im bett drin das ist hier dieser
schlafsack das schlecht jetzt gerade die
kleine lea drin
amiras baby und zwar muss man beim
schlafen hat immer darauf achten dass
man babys nicht mit decken zudeckt
einfach weil die dann die decken im
schlaf über ihr gesicht zum beispiel
ziehen und dann ersticken können
deswegen ist ein schlafsack wirklich
ideal und ich habe jetzt diesen
schlafsack hier also das ist wirklich
eins meiner favoriten oder mein
lieblings schlafsack sag ich mal ich
nutze auch nur den das ist jetzt einer
von cosimo ist ein kurs im schlafsack
den findet meine hebamme übrigens auch
richtig toll und zwar bindet man dann
das baby reihen
ich zeige euch das jetzt mal kurz hier
gibt's noch so zwei knöpfe wird dann
zeitlich eben zog gemacht damit das baby
das sicher drin schlafen kann und
natürlich schläft leider nicht mark
branson hat irgendwie daran aber da
kommt dann das baby rhein kann man rein
legen hier an den seiten zu machen und
dann ist es auch wirklich fest da drin
denn babys mögen das ja auch ganz fest
eben zu gewickelt zu sein und wenn man
das hier dann schön zu binden kann man
dann auch ein bisschen fester binden
das ist dann wie wenn das baby gepackt
wird also mit so einem punkt uhr und
dann stempeln die arme und die beine
nicht so fest
und das baby kann dann einfach ruhiger
schlafen weil es dann eben nicht immer
wieder aufwacht meine eltern haben mit
stroh zugedeckt also ich kenne lkw-plane
bulgarischen lkw also ich kenne das von
auch von meiner mama die hat mir das mal
erzählt dass neben babys spucken kann
eben mit diesem punkt ich finde das hier
halt ganz praktisch geht ganz schnell
und das baby kann da wirklich toll drin
schlafen es ist nicht kalt und ich
brauche auch keine zusätzliche decke und
hier habe ich dann einfach immer noch so
ein tuch darunter dass wenn sie mal
spuckt dass ich nicht jedes mal den
bezug waschen muss dann kann man zwar
auch waschen
aber ich finds halt auch ganz gut so was
nicht oft zu waschen weil das baby dann
ja auch so den eigenen geruch dann immer
riecht und daneben gut darin schlafen
kann weil es eben keine fremde umgebung
ist da immer die bekannte ja so halte
ich es auch bei socken murat finde ich
den als super praktisch weil ich habe
ihn immer in ihrem bett mit drin
ich kann den aber auch einfach so nehmen
und den kinderwagen legen ich kann den
sack mitnehmen und wenn wir zum beispiel
bei freunden unterwegs sind oder
irgendwo unterwegs nehme ich den sack
einfach mit also den schlafsack und kann
dann zum beispiel die ella einfach auf
dem sofa oder auf einem fremden bett
schlafen lassen und sie schläft dann
halt auch echt immer gut
und zum stillen habe ich übrigens hier
hinten
auch diese lampe die kennt ihr von samir
us zimmer und zwar ist es die lampe da
verlinkt ich euch nochmal den schock der
beiden süßen mädels in der infobox und
zwar ist es ganz praktisch weil das sind
so led lichter und die sind halt nicht
so hell und ich sehe trotzdem noch genug
um die ella zu stillen wir haben zwar
hier so nacht lampen gekauft aber die
sind einfach viel zu herrschen
ja ich mache ich wenn ich die anmache
dann ist der ganze raum hell und dann
wache ich erstmal selber zu arg auf und
baby wacht auf und ich brauchen 18 ruhe
und sie soll er nur kurz gestellt werden
und dann wird sie wieder ins bett gehen
aus ich war ich noch nie morath was ich
noch sagen wollte warum ich dieses bett
so toll findet eben weil ich nicht
aufstehen muss ich kann einfach direkt
als ich mache das immer so
ich zeige euch das ist jetzt habe ich
das bett grad nicht eingehakt wegen dem
filmen
aber ich mache immer so sitze ich hier
im bett und nehmen die l darauf könnte
stehen und einfach wieder weglegen und
kann einfach weiterschlafen also mein
schlafe dann auch nicht so arg gestört
und sie wird nicht so arg gestört weil
es einfach direkt wieder ins bett kommt
nach zwickl ich sie übrigens auch nicht
so arg es war auch so ein tipp von einer
hebamme da war wirklich gold wert weil
ich habe es am anfang macht auch immer
alle drei stunden gewickelt und wurzelt
überwachung wollte nicht mehr
einschlafen und seitdem ich das nicht
mehr machen
seitdem ich sie dann eben nur dann
wieder wenn auch wirklich viel drin ist
schläft sie viel besser also wirklich
gut
wir haben das gefühl stands anzeige
nachher man natürlich nett aber man
merkt dass jetzt fröhlich oder nicht ja
auf jeden fall ist dass das beispiel
bett und ich finde es wirklich super
genial
übrigens ist das bett bei uns ich habe
180 breit und hier schlafe ich
normalerweise schläft am ihre
eigentliche im zimmer aber zur zeit
schläft sie halt bei uns hier in der
mitte links schläft der moral und der
hat dann immer ungefähr noch so einen
halben meter platz und wenn ihnen der
platz dann auch zu eng wird oder
sanieren wieder eine rein tritt dann
geht einfach ins amiras findet
dass sie mir drei mädels hier allein als
nächstes zeige ich euch jetzt den
wickeltisch und zwar steht er bei mir im
badezimmer und zwar habe ich bei samira
damals da hatten wir gar keine
wickeltisch da hatte ich im badezimmer
meine waschmaschine und dann habe ich
einfach auf die waschmaschine so eine
decke gelegt oder ein handtuch und habe
so auflagen draufgelegt einfach damit
ich halt im stehen dann die samira
wickeln konnte es ging auch eine ganze
zeit lang gut bis dann irgendwann der
trockner kam wir uns dann trocknen
angeschafft an dienst leider nicht mehr
und ich musste samira teilnehmer auf dem
bett oder auf dem sofa oder woanders
statt wickeln und dieses mal haben wir
uns selbst dessen geholt und zwar aus
dem grund weil ich halt hier in der
wickelkommode und eine badewanne in
einem hub und ich habe das ganze im bad
stehen einfach aus dem grund weil ich ja
zum wickeln immer wasser benutzt also
ich habe hier immer so ein schildchen
und kann mir dann hier direkt aus der
badewanne das wasser holen und dann eben
die ela mit wasser und mit zu kleinen
reinigungstüchern sauber machen weil ich
einfach keine frische feuchttücher
fertig sein weil ich einfach keine
feuchttücher benutzen will daheim weil
es einfach mit wasser eben viel besser
geht und das geniale hier ist einfach
ich habe eine badewanne und die
wickelauflage in einem weil es gibt
nichts schlimmeres als wenn man das baby
baden möchte und dann irgendwie versucht
das im waschbecken zu machen oder auf
der badewanne oder in der badewanne und
es ist halt alles sehr umständlich ich
hatte damals einfach so eine kleine
badewanne und musst du dir dann immer in
die badewanne mit reinstellen und das
war halt sehr unpraktisch und hier liegt
dann einfach die ela her
das ist jetzt die lehrer sanierers baby
und danach leider sehr nackt gebadet
habe ich hier als seine auflage drauf
und zwar sind es diese einweg teile und
zwar einfach aus dem grund dass das hier
nicht immer schmutzig wird und ich das
dann nicht immer waschen muss weil es
kann ja mal passieren dass entwickeln
was daneben geht oder während den wickel
noch was austritt sage ich jetzt mal so
und dann hat man einfach diese auflage
hier
und wenn ich sie dann eben fertig
gewickelt habe oder ich sie zum beispiel
baden möchte nämlich sehr einfach auf
den schoß natürlich mit wendel weil
ansonsten wird man kann ich diese
auflage wegnehmen und wenn ich sie bat
dann habe ich das hat vorher schon
vorbereitet
dann lege ich dass mir hier runter und
habe vorher schon das wasser gerichtet
und das kann ich dann hier einfach
direkt aus der badewanne mit dem
schlauch hier einfühlen kann hier den
stöpsel hier verschließen und dann eben
alles richten
und das finde ich echt genial vor allem
kann ich dann einfach nach dem baden das
wasser wieder abgelassen weil da gibt es
hier zum schlauch und den dass ich dann
hier durch direkt in die badewanne
ablesen und kann dann in der zeit
während das wasser abfließt die elfer
wieder auf den schoß nehmen und dann die
auflage mit einer hand wieder drauf
setzen und kann dann eben einfach weiter
weg bringen und beim fahren ist ganz
wichtig also dass durch die recht
niemand machen
ihr dürft niemals ein baby alleine
lassen also weder beim baden noch beim
wickeln nicht passieren kann dass das
baby in der badewanne sowieso da
ertrinkt das baby und beim wickeln
dürfte das auch nicht allein lassen weil
es einfach runterfallen haben also egal
wie alt sie sind wirklich meine hebamme
ich hab mit ihr darüber und setzt sie
wird wirklich einmal im monat angerufen
weil irgendwann eben baby einfach runter
fällt und das ist wirklich
lebensgefährlich
und als ich jetzt am anfang dieser
wickelauflage und diese wickel bade
kombination mit hatte weil das einfach
noch nicht geliefert werden konnte was
eigentlich auch ganz praktisch ich habe
mich dann hier auf den boden gesetzt und
habe hier als handtücher und
wickelauflage ausgebreitet und das auf
den boden gemacht das ging auch für zwei
wochen ganz gut aber danach wird's
einfach zu anstrengend also in den knie
in unternehmen hinsetzen weil man
wickelt hat wirklich acht bis zehnmal am
tag und deswegen finde ich es ganz
wichtig dass man sich das so bequem wie
möglich macht und dass man aufrecht
stehen kann
aber für mich war es halt so eine
wickelkommode einfach zu groß also ich
wollte keine wickelkommode in
irgendeinem zimmer stehen haben weil ich
ja dann immer in spa treffen muss das
wasser holen muss und hier habe ich halt
alles in einem wirklich praktisch und es
ist übrigens auch der ort der von murat
nie besucht wird weil immer wenn ich
sagen hat komik titel doch mal de la
mafia immer ihnen ausrede also das macht
hat entweder ist die religion ist
verbietet die verbietet es eben also
natürlich nett aber er sagt sand oder
essen
was sind seine nutzer für gründe woran
ich kenne das kind vielleicht könnte es
nicht mehr lieben genau aber irgendwann
kriege ich ein tor noch dazu ja und was
ich hier auch noch richtig genial finde
moment jetzt erste auflage drauflegen so
die auflage benutze ich so oft bisher
halt mal pipi drauf macht sag ich mal so
es ist so oft wie es ausgeht ich las die
das baby jetzt hier liegen aber das ist
kein echtes baby
und hier habe ich nämlich mal was
richtig geniale und zwar haben wir am
anfang die windeln einfach in den
mülleimer geschmissen ich hatte ehrlich
gesagt vergessen wie stark das stinken
kann und jetzt sag mal so einen windel
eimer und zwar hebt der sich von den
anderen ab dazwischen windheimer ich
kann hier ganz normale typen benutzen
und dann nehme ich einfach die dreckige
windeln nehme ich einfach mal das
handtuch
dann kommt die dreckig window rein und
dann wird die verschlossen und wieder
aufgemacht und es fällt halt unten rein
und ich brauche halt für diesen windel
einmal ganz normale typen also nicht
diese kassetten die immer so überteuert
sind und die dann jede einzelne windel
in sich zusammen dreht und das ist echt
richtig günstige anschaffung und richtig
genial aber genau das macht einmal also
du holst dir einmal diesen wind laimer
und ansonsten kannst du ganz normale mit
einer müllbeutel mit rein geben und das
wirklich nur einmalig diese kosten und
das ist wirklich das ist okay
sowohl ja so in 34 tagen ist es voll und
dann nimmt demokratie und bringt ihn
runter erzählt euch auf instagram immer
als ästhet für mich ist es wirklich so
die beste kombination und so die beste
möglichkeit das baby zu wickeln also für
mich persönlich und ich habe hier rechts
übrigens vielleicht kann man das noch
zeigen
habe ich so eine ablage da habe ich
nämlich die windel drin davon die
zaubermacht tücher
hier habe ich noch wie sie in creme und
öl und so weiter und da hinten auch noch
öl und hier unten drin habe ich dann
auch immer ersatz klamotten falls beim
wickeln in jevers schmutzig wird oder
was ausläuft habe ich immer was parat
und muss dann eben die eltern alleine
hier stehen lassen und dann eben noch
meine wattepads und einfach noch nicht
shampoo windeln und so weiter also alles
auf vorrat
meine mutter hat mich übrigens in bach
gewaschen nur so zur info sie
interessiert wahrscheinlich kein baby
weg geht weiter als nächstes zeige ich
euch jetzt den hochstuhl und zwar ist es
jetzt noch der hochschule von samira die
eliza im moment noch ein bisschen zu
klein um zu sitzen
aber sobald sie sitzen kann kriegt sie
auch einen hochstuhl und zwar habe ich
damals wirklich um den stuhl kämpfen
müssen weil murat diesen schuhe gekauft
hat ich glaube das ist so der stuhl der
wahrscheinlich am meisten gekauft wird
ist aus dem schwedischen möbelhaus mam
murats schwäbischer einkauf im
schwedischen möbelhaus brauche ich ein
zungenbrecher ja irgendwie schon
das ist jetzt gerade meine puppe drin
also eigentlich die mainzer raum hat die
petra genannt ich weiß auch nicht warum
das sagte petra das nachbarskind
außerdem eine puppe und hier ist jetzt
erster miras und theo und bei dem stuhl
ist als das blöde ist nicht sicher dass
ich volles plastik eigentlich nur mit in
china und der stuhl also der hat wie
viele andere auch die eigenschaften
kippen kann
sobald das kind sich zum beispiel vorne
also wenn es vorne mit den füßen durch
guckt und sich am tisch zum beispiel
abstößt kann hat der stuhl nach hinten
kippen auf die seite kippen und bei dem
ist eh kein problem weil er sowieso so
leicht ist es einfach bei jedem windstoß
umfallen könnte und deswegen habe ich
damals wirklich sehr stark um diesen
stuhl gekämpft den kennen wahrscheinlich
auch ganz viele das ist der stocke tripp
trapp und das ist mittlerweile auch
schon fünf jahre alt aber ich finde das
sieht mit dem gar nicht so an und samira
sitzt jetzt auch noch auf dem also das
ist ein stuhl der hat am anfang
natürlich auch diesen
baby einsatz vorne dass man eben das
baby direkt so mit einem halben jahr
einsetzen kann und es dann das sicher
drin sitzt der stuhl kanal nicht
umkippen und erwächst mit also die
samira ist jetzt mittlerweile fünf und
sitzt da immer noch drauf und auch ihren
freundinnen kindergarten die haben dann
auch alle oder die meisten und der
wächst halt mit die kann da drauf sitzen
also bis sie 15 ist glaube ich sogar und
jetzt fragt man sich vielleicht wieso
sollte das kind aber so lange auf einem
baby oder auf einem kinderhochstuhl
sitzen und zwar ganz einfach bei diesem
hochstuhl ist halt das problem da wächst
kind halt ziemlich schnell raus so mit
einem jahr ungefähr oder mit zwei passte
halt nicht mehr rein
aber dann ist das kind halt immer noch
zu klein um auf einem normalen stuhl zu
sitzen
das heißt wenn man möchte dass halt das
baby oder das kind am tisch mit ist
müsste man es halt irgendwie keine
ahnung auf dem schoß nehmen oder halt
irgendwas tun auf normale studie
darunter setzen und der stuhl den kampf
einstellen
also hier bis jetzt noch ziemlich weit
oben denn muss jetzt aber wieder
einstellen
da kann man das hier unterstellen und
das hier ist diffus ablage die kammer
auch unterstellen und ganz praktisch
halt auch der murat wenn er mal was aus
einem schrank holen will und er trank
kommt benutzer der stuhl einfach als
dritt leider ziemlich stabil
das ist nicht lustig sind ich finde
schon dass ich mal was kosten der damit
man die leute wissen ja hat gekämpft
hast ich habe den damals wirklich hat
mir den neueren gebraucht haben neu
gekauft hat der glaube ich um die 250
euro gekostet also mit diesem einsatz
und mit diesem baby einsatz
es ist wirklich viel also wirklich total
viel geld für ein stuhl
aber ich finde da war wirklich jeden
cent wert und man bekommt ihr diese
stühle auch wirklich gut gebraucht also
wenn ich jetzt diesen stuhl verkaufen
würde
da ist ja immer noch super also den kann
ich immer noch weitere 30 jahre
wahrscheinlich benutzen da ist halt auch
aus vollem massivholz also wirklich
einfach naturbelassenes holz denn gibt
es in verschiedenen farben dann eben
einfach lackiert und es ist wirklich ein
genialer stuhl
ich werde das nächste mal einfach nur
noch gebraucht kaufen
die gibt es nämlich wirklich ganz toll
und ja
kurs gebraucht so zwischen 60 und 100
euro bekommt man ja ich finde halt auch
so vom aufbau her ist genial weil der
dass ich halt gedanken darüber gemacht
hat hat er gesagt okay ich möchte dass
das kind direkt mit am tisch sitzt ohne
jetzt so inzwischen tisch weil wenn
jetzt das kind da drin sitzt sitzt ja
nicht mit den eltern am esstisch sondern
am eigenen tisch was als ziemlich schade
ich auch gerade für die esskultur und
deswegen also auf den stuhl auf den
specht wirklich genial
also ganz ehrlich fand den augen obwohl
er so teuer war jetzt letztendlich haben
sie wirklich gelohnt
genau und jetzt wenn die eltern eben
groß genug ist dann kriegt sie hat auch
ihren stuhl gebrauchten genau die ricken
gebrauchten und da gibt es dann zum
beispiel auf seiner babyschale sogar
also das könnten wir jetzt eigentlich
auch schon holen und in manchen baby
merken oder in manchen fachgeschäften
kann man sogar die sachen einfach mieten
also das finde ich auch klasse gerade
diesen baby einsatz dann die babyschale
die braucht man nur vier fünf monate das
kann man dann mieten und dann einfach
wieder zurückgeben weil man muss sich ja
echt nicht alles kaufen und als letztes
zeige ich euch jetzt hier noch dieses
laufgitter und zwar habe ich mir das
gewünscht weil ich da einfach mal die
ella einfach reinlegen kann und vor
allem habe ich das halt immer im
wohnzimmer stehen
das heißt wenn ich hier in der küche
arbeiten liegt die ella in dem
laufgitter und es steht daneben neben
dem sofa das ist ganz praktisch habe
jetzt ein großes also das ist ein auf
einen meter und zwar kann man das später
auch als laufstall benutzen
man kann dann einfach hier diese fläche
runtersetzen und sobald sie eben sich
aufrichten kann
und zum beispiel auch stehen kann muss
man es halt unternehmen damit sie eben
nicht herausfallen kann
jetzt liegt sie ja nur um kann sich auch
nicht hochziehen jetzt ist es so hoch
ganz okay und ich habe da jetzt dieses
was wir so eine spielecke hab so einem
spiel der gehört drin
die habe ich noch von der samira und es
ist halt ganz cool ich lege dann da die
eller reihen liegt da jetzt auch gerade
um schläft und macht es dann an das sind
so ganz angenehme dschungel geräusche
was
angenehm ich finde angenehm also murat
nervt total angenehm alles was was
blinkt und ich machte zeit schläft habe
ich noch von samira und die liegt an da
drin und dann spielt sie eben hier
versucht sie jetzt zum beispiel schon
dieses pferdchen zugreifen
zweitens habe ich mit hingehängt und ja
kann sie einfach hier so bisserl ich
meine die hat dann halt eine
beschäftigung kann hier sicher drin
liegen und wenn sie mal einschläft und
schläft zu einer decke ich sie einfach
ein bisschen zu und ich finde gerade so
lauf geht da ganz praktisch auch für
später ich meine jetzt habe ich sie dann
halt immer im blick vor allem wenn ich
hier im wohnbereich bin und sie hat auch
ein bisschen platz nicht so wie in dem
kleinen bettchen und für später ist es
halt ganz praktisch gerade als
laufgitter wenn es dann hier unten ist
kann ich sie wenn sie zum beispiel schon
krabbeln kann und ich muss irgendwie mal
in fahrrad oder auf toilette oder
irgendwohin kann ich sie einfach da rein
setzen und da kann da nichts passieren
und dann komme ich wieder und nehmen sie
einfach wieder raus
ja das ist eigentlich so und ganz
praktisch auch wenn unsere freunde zum
beispiel vorbeikommen die haben die
kleine tochter luisa die ist auch so alt
wie er sie liegen dann einfach
nebeneinander hier drinnen und schlafen
dann oder gucken sich an oder gucken in
die decke oder spielen mit dem also ganz
praktisch wirklich das war jetzt meine
babyausstattung also die sachen die ich
am sinnvollsten findet zumindest für
mich bei euch kann es natürlich
individuell auch ganz anders sein am
besten redet ihr zum beispiel auch mal
mit freunden die zeichen schon babys
haben oder ihr redet mit eurer hebamme
auf jeden fall solltet ihr euch wirklich
eine hebamme suchen auch schon ganz früh
denn hebammen sind wirklich also man
findet immer ganz schwer
und ich war auch ganz froh dass ich eine
richtig gute hebamme hat oder immer noch
mehr habe und die kann euch dann auch
individuell beraten weil die sie dann
auch bei euch zu hause wie es bei euch
aussieht wie ihr vielleicht eher
verhalten zu hause hat was ihr daneben
benötigt und für mich waren jetzt dass
so die sachen wo ich sagen kann ok das
war es für mich wichtig ich habe
natürlich auch aus der ersten
schwangerschaft schon vieles mit an
erfahrungen genommen und wusste dann was
brauche ich was brauche ich dieses mal
nicht wo soll ich eher den fokus darauf
legen und dann hat sich dem das so alles
heraus kristallisiert wenn ihr möchtet
kann ich gerne mehr videos machen auch
gerne zu anderen themen was jetzt baby
und kind betrifft dann müsste mir
einfach schreiben in die kommentare
ich habe dir einfach vorschläge ich
glaube viele hat auch interessiert wie
ich mein tragetuch zum beispiel gebunden
habe oder auch diese babytrage die wir
haben also ich kann euch da gerne auch
videos dazu drehen und das kinderwagen
video verlinkt ihr euch auf jeden fall
noch mal in der infobox da könnte auf
jeden fall noch mal reinschauen
ich freue mich wenn euch das video
gefallen hat und morgen kommt wieder ein
neues leckeres rezept video also bis
morgen auf wiedersehen